let me pivot to the thing that kind of
came out of the blue yesterday yeah joe
judge a guy that you know from your time
in new england the head coach first year
of the new york giants he made jason
garrett the former cowboys coach the
offensive coordinator garrett brought
mark colombo to coach the offensive line
and as i think it finally was told by
multiple reports that have been
synthesized and harmonized and
cut and paced and snarky commented
dave de googly elmo was going to be
brought in to consult with the offensive
line right
mark colombo did not react well to that
yada yada yada mark columbo got fired
now we don't know what the yada
entailed
was it loud voices
was it a little pushy chubby
was it a little punchy facey i don't
know right the giants denied
that there was a fist fight between joe
judge and mark colombo well there could
be a fight that's not a fist fight and
rarely if ever does an actual fight be
between two grown men look like rocky it
doesn't happen that way it's an ugly
mess of flailing that ultimately results
in someone trying to knock the other guy
down typically right unless you're
dealing with trained fighters it's an
ugly mess so who knows what ultimately
happened chris but it was enough to get
mark colombo summarily and immediately
fired yeah no i mean uh the first thing
is
i've i've been told there was no fight
all right i mean as you can imagine i
know some people in the giants
organization all right so that's what i
was told from the get-go there was no
fight was there some intense argument
and some pissed offness okay sorry
london for pissed off this
but was there some of that and some
swearing and some intense you know
moments in a conversation definitely
that is everything i've been told by
multiple people there so i i would have
a hard time thinking a f a fight broke
out also i mean joe judge he's gonna
have to show his face here at some point
in the next few days
i mean
sunglasses sunglasses maybe a guy like
you know mark columbo has been in the
nfl you know
there's not going to be a lot of swings
and misses if it came down to a punching
fight that way also the other thing
people got to remember here too you know
if you're an offensive line coach and
you want to have a future in the nfl
you're not going to have a great future
if you're famous for punching out your
bosses all right and getting in fights
with them so that is like totally a
no-no as we know it's a very military
like
you know uh what do i want to say
chain commandment whatever in the nfl
search chain of command chain command
exactly
page 237 chain commandment i can
understand why he got pissed and he's
mad because of course he doesn't want
anybody there looking over him the
offensive line with the new york giants
and what mark colombo has done has been
a lot better lately i mean we sit there
you see wayne gallman and doing what
he's doing but joe judge has a prior
relationship with with the googly elmo
so he's worked with him in new england
and he's a really good offensive line
coach and obviously he wanted something
done the way he wanted it done and
colombo didn't like that and that was
that but
again
multiple people not a fight intense
yelling pissed off this yes not a fight
question yeah
and i don't want to slip into the old
lawyer cross examination mode but is it
true
that from time to time
coaches
get upset
when they're
on the job definitely isn't it true
isn't it true that that happens yes and
isn't it true that at times the voices
get raised and and guys get in each
other's faces isn't it true that that
happened that does it doesn't happen a
lot but it does happen no doubt
and isn't it true that even sometimes
there's just that little bit of of of
jostling not not not a fight but just a
little just i've seen some i've seen
some you know in your face i'm hitting
you with your chest i want to punch you
but i'm not going to do it yes i've seen
all of that yes it's not abnormal right
it's all right it's not abnormal it's
not abnormal no okay well whatever
mark columbo did yesterday crossed those
lines yeah if there's a certain amount
of it that's normal whatever he did
went far enough beyond it to justify him
being fired not tomorrow
not today
not next week right not suspended with
pay while hr looks into it yeah fired
out the door gone today so so that tells
me the guy did something
that was beyond the pale that was across
the line well so i think it's more than
the garden variety hey oh yeah
fu no fu no hey you know puffing your
chest out and bumping each other it's
something more than that i i i'm not
trying to say that it was some cordial
conversation i and i will i'm not i'm i
you're right if i sounded that way no i
think it was an uh more of an argument
and a yelling and a shouting match than
normal definitely and a lot of four
letter words were thrown out and
everything like that now listen that's a
little bit gonna be a little bit of the
environment there i mean joe judge is
from philly and he's an in-your-face guy
and he ain't gonna back down from
anybody and i don't know mark columbo
but i know just the way he looks and
from people i've heard too he ain't
gonna back down from anybody either so
i'm sure when he got bad news that he
was gonna have somebody there and he
feels like man you're gonna have them
looking over my shoulder and doing all
that type of crap he got pissed off and
it probably became a you know f-u-f this
and they went at each other and he said
i don't want to do that i don't want to
be a part of this pro this crap probably
that's where i'm guessing where it went
i'm not going to be a part of it and he
probably quit fired whatever he just
said it's not going to happen and i
think that's where it goes see that
that's the thing right
if he quit then he quit
right now he if if he got fired
then
he gets he gets he gets paid so no yes
yeah you you don't want to you don't
want to quit right you don't want to
quit or if the guy is going to quit this
is another michael scott lesson if the
guy is going to quit don't fire him
like tony when they did the merger of
stamford and scranton
let him quit then you don't owe him
anything don't fire him michael scott so
who knows but it's not the garden
variety
normal no it's nothing that happens from
time to time especially with a losing
team although they're that's what's
funny the giants aren't losing right
that's what i was just gonna say i mean
if you really look at things right now
that's where it's shocking you go man
the giants are on the right track right
now i mean joe judge is doing great
things and i you know the offensive line
like i said it's been a lot better
lately jason garrett's got the offense
going i mean the defense has shut out
some really good offenses i mean there's
a lot that i'm as a giant fan i'm pumped
about right now you know i was shocked
to hear that development i will say
though i'm not shocked that they want to
bring in dave to googly elmo he's a
really damn good offensive line coach a
really good one and there's history
there so you know obviously there was
something with the way colombo was
coaching or something there that joe
judge just obviously didn't agree with
and and uh that's where it went off the
rails
and uh yeah and and look maybe columbo
sensed that it was just a first step
toward him being exactly right anyway
yeah this is just the phase in right you
don't bring in a veteran established
offensive line coach as a consultant
with just this general he's just going
to consult for the rest of the year
he's either going to take over
during the season or as soon as the
season ends mark columbo see you later
you don't need two offensive line
coaches no
and these and these are two guys mike
that too you know again i don't know
columbo but just from what i know i know
to googly elmo a little bit like they're
not
these are two you know these are two
commanders it'd be i don't think it
would be that great necessarily with two
commanders in the room anyways they'd
probably butt heads eventually that's
where i just you know i bet you mark
colombo knew that a little too and of
course he doesn't want anybody looking
over him in that way and you're right
and who knows what he says who knows
what he says you know i doubt he quit
you know to your point maybe he just
goes well you know i'm gonna be not
given a hundred percent or something
like that to where it kind of forces you
to fire him instead of him not having to
quit
whatever it was it doesn't happen very
often which is why it was such a big
story yesterday
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports